michael vsauce here and if flat earth
were pants would it wear them like this
or like this
[Music]
earth isn't flat then how come our shoes
are like this and not like this I'm just
playing around guys we're just having
fun here laughing at Flat Earth thinners
how original
how clever take such bravery to be such
contrarian in today's society isn't it
fun to just laugh at other people from
unlikable celebrities like Tila Tequila
have a slight tilt where was the tilt
dice I'm still looking forward to dying
rappers like VOB I'd like to thank
everybody who donated to appreciate it
however I made a few alterations to the
campaign by raising the original amount
from 200,000 to a million because you
wanted more money I see what you're
doing Bob I would love to have a million
dollars to prove that the earth is
actually round that would be great check
out the GoFundMe in the description guys
I think if we can finally set an end to
this debate together as long as I get
all the money but what is an actual Flat
Earth inert looked like well luckily
they all went together at a convention
so let's investigate this is a day
that's gonna be etched in history the
quest for Troy and it can seem crazy but
all of us laugh at this topic including
myself this is probably the most
ridiculous thing I ever thought did I be
doing and Here I am organizing the Flat
Earth international conference but I'm
not laughing anymore there's a lot of
people that have different ideas on what
the Flat Earth is but what one things we
all agree on is that we don't live on a
spinning ball flying to infinite space
do you feel yourself spinning wobbling
gyrating now I'm pretty rock solid eh if
I can't feel the gravity then how can
you be real huh no I'm pretty rock solid
explain that to me huh I feel rock solid
where I'm standing there therefore the
earth must be play it's science
based on my cell toilet waters not
flying out on people in Australia
because of gravity wait wait a minute
yeah Australia are you okay are you okay
over there Australian yeah I'm gonna my
Justin [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
am I just supposed to drink this how
does the end to my system if the Earth's
round doesn't make any sense
I need to conduct an experiment so if I
drink it upside down
there's no way it should be able to
enter my sister
my nose it's fizzy water
your move flat earthers well hello
it doesn't fly out of the toilet because
water seeks its level water ceases level
that doesn't make any sense none of this
makes any sense
water ceased level then how come I can
drink it upside down I say just
demonstrated Flat Earth inertia you need
to become more consistent with your
theories please don't waste my time the
Flat Earth would be a circular flat area
surrounded by a field that is known as
Antarctica this white rim someone didn't
give this man enough attention as a
child I need to find some way so I can
be special too
this woman is amazing by the way this
line I love so much it's white rim
around the outside a lot of people refer
to it as the ice wall yes of course the
ice wall of course
welcome
why doesn't water fall off the planet if
the earth is flat ice wall you silly
dumb panty tents I mean I'm actually
being sold more and more on this theory
it the more I hear about it the more he
makes sense this picture don't make me
laugh that's unrealistic okay where is
the ice wall guys there's not even a
turtle underneath it I believe that some
kind of star field firmaments about six
thousand miles above us it appears to be
this guy is like alt reality
shaggy from scooby-doo he also just
tosses strange words around to to sort
of prove his point a cymatic light field
electromagnetic energy not gravity at
all gravity's a deception the Sun the
moon are these transcendental cymatic
the sun in the move are this transid
etic ciphering and lunin morphix it's
science Neil deGrasse Tyson wouldn't
tell you about that that's right the
best way to prove something is through
right all science should be based on rap
music alright if Stephen Hawking is
isn't rapping it then I don't want to
hear it just don't waste my time for my
mother if I tried to talk to her about
any of these things she doesn't believe
me I just can't take that rejection took
my mother
[Music]
with our money they're lying I ain't
buying who's they
well basically Satan ya see this water
it's being manipulated right now and I'm
a Christian channel so I'm able to
transmute it fuse it so that it stays in
the water bottle as far as I know I'm
the first guy in the whole world to make
a working physical model of the platter
that is not an achievement
this is alt reality Logan Paul I'm the
first one guys I'm the first one to do
this insane I think I named this one
hidden lands beyond because some of us
think that there's other lands that
they're hiding from so this is a fantasy
game but in the game you have the prime
material plane yep let's step away from
that guys there's an opening right there
in the ice wall I can't believe we never
see this do you see this there's an
escape we can escape through the other
lands to to do what exactly they
discover these other lands and they just
don't want us to know about it I mean
you know we might want to go there
repopulate it I mean you know if ladders
was like guarantee it
but you don't know who they are because
they're afraid of talking about it but
I'm not a flatter thinner so box yeah
we're going this is crazy right but
think about this for the last 2025
generations this is what we've told
people oh my god of course since we used
to believe it then it totally makes
sense just like we believe that contents
didn't move or that babies don't feel
pain or that the size and shape of your
head determines your behavior that's
right we used to think it so it has to
be true
well I've watched over 50 hours of video
that's it that's how you know if you
watch a lot of YouTube videos that's
evidence
and I did my own testing what was the
tests take do you take a straight edge
and you go from one end and you follow
the horizon of the horizon yeah that's a
straight edge just to the other end and
it's it's flat we can experiment is that
I just walk across the shore from like
20 m/s and like I didn't see your curve
it never showed up and I just kept
walking and she's never showed up
doesn't make any sense
one of my favorite flat earth owners
Glenn Hall aka not a fool man he's a
mathematician and he's taking judge
court cases that no one else would take
I call this video the simplest
irrefutable flat every beautiful now I
know there's gonna be some people some
people not me watch this hmm who know me
personally and people who know me
personally know that I am NOT a fool
he's not a fool guys I have a degree in
math and I have a juris doctorate and I
have been practicing law for almost 30
years Wow now notice as I am going south
I have to continue dipping the nose of
my airplane in order to stay level with
that's right you don't even have to do
that because of gravity it's great it's
fantastic I'm gonna continue all the way
to Antarctica oh my god he's right why
doesn't he just fly off to space
continuing to dip down and finally I get
down here to Antarctica and look at that
he's upside down my airplane is upside
down you can learn about you can test
gravity yourself just take a bucket with
water in it and spin it why does it
would stay in debug Italy this is like
first grade level stuff
I think they cling to it because it
feels to them like they have special
knowledge that other people aren't aware
of and that that
you a sense of purpose and a sense of
meaning there's no thing it's a dead
meme at this point and I think we should
just drop the whole laughing at them as
well it's not doing anyone a favor I
honestly I sympathize with these people
clearly they are lacking something in
their life to cling on to these obscure
ideas and probably best to just leave it
at that
[Music]
[Applause]